Để không cảm thấy bất ngờ mỗi khi nhận được hoa đơn tiền định nhất là vào những tháng cao điểm nặng nắm,
nhưng người trọn cách chù động theo dõi lượng định tưu thủ hàng ngày bằng các ứng dụ của AVN từ hiểu th khu vực sự dụng.
AVN thành nội chăm sóc khách hàng, thành nội AVN ở PC chăm sóc khách hàng, mình bắt, chương hành nội.
AVNC PC chăm sóc khách hàng, mình chung và AVN S-PC chăm sóc khách hàng, mình nằm.
Nguyên dân chỉ cần tại AVN, AVN, Hoặc U-Go Play, Android, sau đó đang nhập bằng má khách hàng ít trên hoa đơn định hoặc tiền nhắn tiền định hàng tháng.
Sau khi đăng nhập và mục định năng tiêu thủ, chỉ số công tư hoặc đều đồ phụ tại để xem số định sự dụng theo ngày.
Dưới lượng được cập nhận tự động từ công tư định tư, thì hiện rõ từ mức tư thủ và sò sáng với những ngày trước đó.
Ngoài việc dút chú động kìm xuất việc sự dụng định, ứng dụng AVN có thể chắc kêu thông tin, lịch kì chỉ dụng,
nhưng tư tiền định, lịch tạm ngừng cùng cấp định, định năng tiêu thủ, thông tin thình tỏng tiền định, chắc kêu hoa đơn.
Vì cập nhận liên tục này xuất người rất chủ động hơn trong điều trình phá quên sự dụng định, chẳng bị động khi hoa đơn tăng đồ bến.